The thing is,
whenever I look at a political movement,
especially ideological,
I think,
okay,
there's a bunch of things your for fine,
what are you against?
You know,
because one of the things that people
who adopted need theological position,
like to presume is that all of the right
is on their site and that makes them
very unconscious up their shadow.
Let's say from a union perspective.
The Nazis had all sorts of positive
reasons for what they were doing,
but you know,
the negative reasons were there too and
you could easily make it a case that the
negative reasons were really the
reasons.
And when I look at video logs,
I always think,
yeah,
that's what you're for sure,
but I don't believe all the good people
are on your site and be.
I know that negative motivations are
more powerful than positive ones.
So you say you're for things,
but you're against them too.
So let's,
let's start with that.
So I thought I started thinking about
this after I read George Orwell.
I love George Orwell,
by the way.
How many of you know who George Orwell
is?
Wow.
Really?
That's impressive.
How many don't.
Okay,
well that's,
that's good.
That's amazing.
How the hell did you learn about George
Orwell's?
Nineteen 84.
Fundamentally,
or animal farm?
Animal Farm.
Okay.
Well that's good because George Orwell,
man,
I tell you,
George Orwell was the first western
intellectual who figured out what the
hell was going on in the Soviet Union.
And he did that in the mid forties,
early.
You know what was complicated because we
sort of knew what was happening in the
twenties and the thirties,
you know,
there was lennon and that wasn't so
good.
There was the Russian civil war,
there was the idea of universal
communism that wasn't such a good idea,
you know,
for,
as far as people who didn't want to be
communists were concerned.
And then there was what happened in the
Ukraine in the 1930.
So it was like,
you know,
the evidence was starting to pile up.
But unfortunately what happened was the
Spanish civil war and the lefties were
pretty much the good guys in the Spanish
civil war.
Right.
It was like a microcosm of the Second
World War.
The lefties were fighting the fascists
and some of the lefties were communists,
but a lot of them were also people who
were,
I think genuinely fighting for freedom
and a lot of North American literary
figures went to Spain to fight on the
side of the.
No,
you know,
against the fascists.
And so fair enough,
you know,
the fascist were obviously,
reprehensible clearly and so and so that
kind of muddied the water right because
the fastest were bad.
And then that sort of means that people
that are fighting them,
their garden and some of them are
communists and there was good.
There was pretty good reason for people
to be radical socialist at that point in
human history because the plight of the
working man was relatively unpleasant.
George Orwell wrote a book called road
to Wigan Pier and he went up to this
town that was a coal mining town and he,
he stayed with the coal miners for
awhile and just looked at their life.
So here,
here's a part of their life.
So you work at seven and a half hour
shift when you're a coal miner and you
think,
oh,
that's not too bad by 1930 standards.
It's like,
yeah,
except you have to go down to the coal
mine tunnels,
you know,
and like they're not eight feet high and
carpeted there like four and a half feet
high and rough and poorly lit and the
ers terrible.
And so basically you have to chimp walk
or crawl up to three miles just to get
to work and then you have to do that at
the end of your shift and you don't get
paid for that.
That's just,
that's your commute,
right?
Right.
So you know,
it was no bloody well.
And then of course what you're doing
when you get there,
it's like it's absolutely filthy.
It's unbelievably noisy.
It's brutally difficult.
He said the coal miners,
they have no teeth because they're like,
because of their living conditions,
but their bodies were absolutely
perfect.
They were unbelievably powerful and
strong because all they did was
incredibly intense physical labor,
but it was bloody rough.
And the housing,
those people had like 50 families for
one outhouse,
that's probably good enough to describe
it.
And often they were row houses and the
row houses had no back doors that may
add no pass between them.
And all the old houses were at the back.
So that meant if you were was like 20
below and it was the winter and you were
sick,
then you get to go all the way around
the block to your damn.
I will tell us where maybe there's only
one there and you line up with 50 people
so that.
Yeah.
So in order while he was orwell was an
upper class guy basically,
and he was trying to help themselves
overcome these upperclass prejudices who
is a real documentary,
one of the terrible working conditions
of,
of working class people.
And he wrote this book called Road to
Wigan Pier.
But one of the things that or will said,
he wrote this story about these poor God
damn coal miners and you think,
well yeah,
it's like how about some social
legislation so that these people and
their children aren't just absolutely
brutalized nonstop.
You know.
But then he wrote the last half of the
book and he wrote it for the left book
club,
which was a socialist group that we
publish a book every month or so.
And what he did was he.
He wrote a critique of socialism of
pretty socialism and he said,
yeah,
well this sucks man.
It's like we should be on the.
Sorry to these working people,
but the social assigned meet,
they're not on the side of the working
people.
They're like tweed wearing middle class
hyper intellectuals who never go
anywhere near the working class because
of their class.
Prejudice isn't for all sorts of other
reasons and they don't like the poor at
all.
They just hate the rich.
And I thought I had been a member of the
NDP for a long time.
At that point.
It was always something a little off
about it.
Especially the more radical kind that's
with you guys is it doesn't look like
benevolence as far as I can tell.
There's a lot of whining and complaining
and resentment.
It's like,
what's that?
What's that about?
I read Orwell and I thought,
right,
if you hate the successful,
if you hate the rich,
who are rich by the way is whoever has
more money than you.
Right?
That's how you define rich and the best
way to mask your resentment,
just to pretend that you're on the side
of the poor.
And I read that.
I thought that's exactly right.
And then that's part of also what made
me psychoanalytically oriented because
one thing psychoanalysts always do
always is if you say you're,
here's how I'm positively predisposed.
The psychoanalyst says,
how are you using that to mask something
easy and malevolent that you're doing?
And that's always.
That's a very,
very useful questions.
Not always correct,
right?
But,
but it's correct a lot more than people
generally like to think,
you know,
it's like the mothering him grant the
mother or the witch in Hansel and
Gretel.
You know the story,
right?
This guy gets married,
he's got a couple of kids.
His new wife doesn't relate to the kids.
You have 100 times higher chance by the
way of being abused by a step parent
than the biological parent.
Just so you know,
so the step where they're just like the
kids,
she tells the guy,
well,
why don't you just go with those kids
out in the woods,
sold out.
They go out in the woods.
So they're lost kids,
right?
They have nowhere to go.
So when they're wandering around out
there in the forest,
what happens?
They come across a gingerbread house.
You think,
wow man,
you're a starving kid.
Just your bread house.
That's good news,
right?
Not only is it a house,
but it's made out of candy.
How could anything possibly be any
better?
So when they go,
well,
and then there's this grandmother type
type and you know,
she's starts to fatten them up and she
puts,
I think it's handling the cage and she
gets settled after a while to basically
work as their scullery maid and equip
becomes quite obvious to the children
that she's actually fattening them up so
that she can put them in the oven and
eat them.
And so I think what Hansel does is I
think gretel gives him this leg bone
from some animal and the old,
which half blind and every time she
reaches into sort feel is laying,
he gives her the bone and so like she's
just not all that interested in meeting
them in anyways.
The kids ended up pushing her in the
oven and closing it and getting the hell
out of there.
So you know,
it's a happy ending as far as fairy
tales school.
But it's an atypical story,
right?
It's a classic story,
but it needed whole family.
Be bloody wary of people who do too much
for you.
Right?
It's like if you have a mother or any
other relatives for that matter,
who's fattening you up on mercy and
candy,
the probability that her basic goal is
to eat you enough so that you never
leave.
The probability is extraordinarily high
and that's no joke.
You know,
one of the things that you do learn if
you read about the sorts of people who
burst out of their mother's basement and
go shoot up Dawson colleges that often.
That's exactly the situation that you've
been,
right.
They're burning with resentment in their
uselessness down in the basement for
five or six years,
you know,
they don't have to leave,
they don't have to become independent,
everything's done for them.
So they never have to do anything for
themselves.
It's like it's not pretty.
And so one of the rules for dealing with
people,
and I know this is actually a rule for
dealing with elderly people in,
in,
in hopes for,
for,
for retired people,
is do not do anything for anyone they
can do for themselves.
You are stealing from them when you do
that.
And it's a great rule of thumb for kits.
Like once they can dress themselves,
they dress themselves.
If they can set the table,
even if it takes 20 minutes,
it's like they're setting the table.
You're not doing them a favor by helping
them do anything they can do themselves
and it gets Kinda,
it's Kinda harsh,
you know,
but it beats the hell out of the witch
in Hansel and Gretel.
So.
So anyways,
one of the things we're going to look at
as well as the dark side of positive
motivations.